congratulations your kubernetes
application is in production and the
number of services you own are growing
but as you scale your services in
production you also need to scale your
monitoring
after all you can't fix what you don't
monitor and your monitoring needs to be
as reliable as your application
prometheus is the standard kubernetes
monitoring system which helps you
collect store query and alert on metrics
important to your applications and
infrastructure
as you scale up it can become
challenging to configure and manage
prometheus to keep up with the volume of
metrics from all of your successful
services this can be a thankless task
after all your users don't care about
how you manage your monitoring
infrastructure they care about making
sure they can use your app google cloud
managed service for prometheus is
designed to help you scale your
prometheus-based monitoring
it's fully managed by google removing
operational toil from tasks like
sharding prometheus servers
managing complex scrape configurations
and federating prometheus servers to
make a global data source
by using the same planet scale time
series database that google uses for its
own monitoring
managed service for prometheus enables
users to collect metrics at incredible
scale with zero operational overhead
this puts global monitoring and alerting
within reach enabling you to gather
metrics from all of your services across
the planet
metrics collection within your gke
clusters also becomes easier
as managed service for prometheus
provides managed collectors that you can
run in your various clusters these no
longer need to maintain state in your
own environment as they are built to
write to and store metrics in managed
service for prometheus
all this said
managed service for prometheus is an
in-place replacement for running your
own prometheus servers
which means you can keep using your
existing prometheus alerts and your
existing grafana dashboards managed
service for prometheus supports any
application that uses promql to query
metrics
you can also utilize its integrations
with google cloud monitoring to get
started you'll need to take two steps
first enable managed service for
prometheus in your gke cluster and
deploy prometheus collectors
these can be deployed alongside your
existing prometheus servers
these collectors will be configured to
write metrics directly to manage service
for prometheus
second connect clients such as grafana
or other tools you may use to read
prometheus metrics from managed service
for prometheus
and that's it with managed service for
prometheus now you're ready to spend
less time configuring monitoring
infrastructure and more time adding the
next big feature to your app
want to learn more
check out more details in the links
below
[Music]